85 exposants dont 240 français sont
installés depuis deux jours au parc des
expositions de villepinte
dans ses galeries un peu spécial on
trouve de tout de la simple cuillère en
passant par le dernier lave vaisselle
pour aboutir à la cuisine toute équipée
mais ce salon n'est ouvert qu'aux
professionnels
il se veut d'abord lieu de rencontres et
d échanges entre fabricants et
distributeurs je me fous fini par tout
cet aspirateur qui est un peu le cousin
dit y est le dernier né de la gamme des
mangeurs de pousser et en plus vous
l'avez entendu il parle a recommandé
pour les personnes solitaires en mal de
conversations il deviendra votre
propriété souple pour la modique somme
de 450 francs
plus sophistiqué cette cuisine tous les
équipements sont reliés à un ordinateur
dont le fonctionnement est paraît-il
d'une simplicité enfantine
nous on veut bien le croire mais on
s'est renseigné si l'ordinateur tombe en
panne on peut néanmoins mettre les
différents appareils sur commande
manuelle
cette cabine spatiale sera en vente tous
équipements fournis pour 40000 francs
avec la notice d'explication c'est ce
qui coûte le plus cher
je crois au contraire justement que à
l'heure actuelle les programmations
électroniques ont été relevés dans le
sens au contraire une simplification de
l'utilisation pour les utilisent pour
les usagers enfin pour les écologistes
en mal le remède naturel beaucoup plus
simple cette auto cuiseur vapeur avec
cette marmite
vous pourrez extraire jus de fruits ou
de légumes à volonté et même les
conserver aussi longtemps que vous le
désirerez mise à prix dans le commerce
250 francs un conseil pour les éventuels
visiteurs se munir d'une bonne paire de
chaussures
il y à plus de 70 millimètres carrés à
parcourir